we resurrect the most lethal predators  this planet has ever seen come on yeah  kid we've taken things way too far  genetic power has now been unleashed  they're not on an island anymore this  has to end we've entered a new era  welcome to Jurassic world ready pg-13  save the dinosaurs from an island that's  about to explode what could go wrong  hello and welcome to the set of Jurassic  world fallen Kingdom now you don't need  us to tell you that dinosaurs are the  biggest creatures ever to walk the earth  and one of the ways to really appreciate  them is on the big screen because every  nail-biting  every narrow escape every thrilling is a  moment worth paying for  you